- You just celebrated your
daughter's graduation.
That's amazing.
(audience applauds)
So are you and Catherine
ready to be empty nesters?
- Yeah, I think so.
I mean, we had a lovely experience.
It was a virtual graduation.
We couldn't actually be in
the same room that she was in
because of COVID
protections and all of that.
And it was so wonderful,
and I'm so proud of her.
But I gotta tell you, Kelly,
it's a little rough when
you're going out the doors
and the other parents are
saying, "Oh, congratulations."
Say, "Thank you. Congratulations to you."
"I see you must be so proud
of your granddaughter."
(group laughs)
- I said, "Well..." (laughs)
- [Kelly] That's-
- I don't know, man. I don't know.
Yeah. Okay.
I'm not gonna take it personal.
I think they're just trying
to be nice, but yeah.
- [Kelly] Just lean in.
- We were getting ready
for it, and we prepared,
but then when the COVID happened
and we had everybody
back home this past year.
But there is that moment
when they're gone and
they're out of the house
and they're gone and
you look at each other,
and in the back of your
mind you're thinking,
what are we gonna talk about?
(group laughs)
What are we gonna talk about?
I mean, I know-
- You get to date again.
You get to date again!
- Well, you do.
Well, you can do all that.
- Yeah!
- But you really, as a marriage,
so much of your time revolves
around talking about your
kids, what they're doing,
how are they doing, and this and that.
It's an easy conversation.
So I think we're gonna do real well.
We got our suitcases packed.
The COVID's getting down.
We're looking to do a lot of traveling
the next couple of years, moving around.
I'm gonna be working over here in Europe
for a lot of this next year.
So we'll be okay.
- Wow!
That's excite, I know I always love that.
I think you get to start dating again.
I think that's fun.